bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat hier en début de soirée
les sénateurs ont rejeté le projet de
loi relatif au droits des étrangers en
2e lecture et cela sans même avoir
débattu des articles la raison de ce
rejet expéditif le fait que l'Assemblée
nationale lors de la navette
parlementaire est fait tableeras sur le
travail du Sénat au mois d'octobre
dernier en première lecture le Sénat
avait fortement modifié le texte avait
durci ce texte qui était par exemple
passé au niveau de son intitulé d'un
texte sur le droit des étrangers à un
projet de loi sur la maîtrise de
l'immigration les sénateures avaient
également transformé l'aide médicale
d'État en aide médicale d'urgence enfin
ils avaient instauré des quotas maximum
d'accueil d'étrangers chaque année mais
voilà au-delà de ces amendements
politiques de de ces amendements
qualifiés même de communiqué de presse
par certains sénateurs socialistes il y
avait eu un véritable travail de juriste
sur ce texte par les sénateurs qui
avaient cherché à clarifier à simplifier
le texte à mettre au niveau du règlement
ce qui devait l're tout en restant dans
la logique du gouvernement mais voilà
même ces amendements-l ont été rejetés
en bloc par l'Assemblée nationale du
coup les deux chambres sont restés
campés sur leur position et le Sénat
hier a décidé de rejeter le texte
directement après la discussion générale
en adoptant une motion opposant la
question préalable tout de suite donc
retour à ce débat c'était hier dans
l'hémicycle monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vous
allez examiner dans quelques minutes en
nouvelle lecture le projet de loi
relatif au droits des étrangers vous en
avez déjà longuement débattu en première
lecture je vais à aller en introduction
à l'essentiel le gouvernement déplore le
fait que la commission mixte paritaire
est échoué tout d'abord parce que le
projet de loi constitue l'ultime étape
de la grande réforme engagée par le
gouvernement concernant la législation
applicable aux étrangers en France que
nous avions entamé l'année dernière au
mois de juillet avec la loi sur l'asile
et le vote à une large majorité de la
loi du 29 juillet 2015 15 cette cette
loi nous a permis de moderniser nos
procédures et de nous placer en
situation de faire face à la grave crise
migratoire à laquelle l'Union européenne
est confrontée depuis plus d'un an si
nous regrettons l'échec de la commission
mixte paritaire c'est aussi parce que le
projet de loi relatif au droits des
étrangers contient plusieurs
dispositions importantes nous permettant
de répondre au faille qui pénalise notre
politique migratoire depuis trop
longtemps notre premier obje constitue
consiste en fait à mieux accueillir et à
mieux intégrer les étrangers qui vivent
légalement sur notre sol nous sommes
revenus longuement sur ces débats lors
de nos échanges pour se faire nous
souhaitions que chaque étranger qui
s'installe légalement et durablement en
France puisse disposer de tous les
outils nécessaires pour bien s'intégrer
à la société française puis s'il en fait
le choix pour rejoindre notre communauté
nationale grâce à la naturalisation
la France doit aider ceux qui souhaitent
la rejoindre et s'approprier notre
langue et les valeurs universelles que
nous défendons aujourd'hui les étrangers
qui vivent en France sont soumis à un
véritable parcours administratif du
combattant c'est la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement a proposé de changer de
logique en consacrant le principe de
l'accès à un titre de séjour pluriannuel
après la première année de séjour ce qui
permettra aux étrangers d'éviter des
allées et retours en préfecture la
création de ce titre s'accompagnera de
deux évolutions indispensables tout
d'abord un renforcement du parcours
d'intégration qui devra s'accompagner de
cours de langue renforcé nous en avions
longuement parlé ensuite parce que nous
sommes dans un état de droit un
renforcement des outils dont disposent
les préfectures pour lutter contre la
fraude avec l'instauration d'un droit de
communication la préfecture n'aura plus
à demander à la personne concernée
qu'elle pour qu'elle fournisse des
pièces mais Onira les chercher dès lors
que l'administration en dispo nous en
gagneront en temps en efficacité le
deuxième grand objectif de cette de ce
projet de loi consiste dans la contexte
de la mondialisation qui accroit la
concurrence entre États à renforcé
l'attractivité de notre pays pour les
talents et les étudiants étrangers nous
proposons d'inscrire dans notre
législation deux innovations la première
la création d'un titre unique dit
passeport talent destiné à tous les
étrangers dont nous souhaitons qu'il
viennent en France ce titre valable 4
ans renouvelable regroupe et élargit
certaines catégories de titres existants
deuxièmement la simplification du
passage de statut d'étudiant au statut
de salariés pour que les meilleurs
étudiants puissent concrétiser dans leur
vie professionnelle les espoirs que la
France a placé en eux en leur permettant
de venir étudier chez nous pour résumer
avec le titre de séjour pluriannuel et
le passeport talent nous souhaitons
renforcer notre législation en matière
de droit au séjours et l'adapter aux
réalité de la mondialisation nous
pourrons ainsi mieux tenir compte des
mobilités liées à la connaissance au
savoir et à la culture nous intégreront
mieux les étrangers sur notre sol et
enfin nous lutterons plus efficacement
contre la fraude voilà quels sont les
points auxquels le gouvernement était
attaché j'en viens maintenant à la lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière qui
était le troisème objectif de notre
texte à cet égard le gouvernement fera
toujours preuve de la plus grande
fermeté un étranger en situation
irrégulière doit être reconduit à la
frontière et les filières criminelles de
l'immigration clandestine doivent être
démantelé il en va du respect de l'État
de droit pour que la lutte que nous
menons contre l'immigration irrégulière
soit pleinement efficace il nous faut
remédier à trois types de faiblesses
c'était également l'objectif de ce texte
tout d'abord nous avons mal transposé
dans le droit français certains aspects
de la directive européenne retour par
conséquent ce n'est que de façon
exceptionnel que les étrangers à qui
nous remettons une mesure d'éloignement
font l'objet de l'interdiction de retour
prévu par les textes européens or
celle-ci peut permettre aux préfectures
de renforcer l'efficacité de leur action
deuxièmement notre politique
d'éloignement repose trop exclusivement
sur la rétention en conformité avec les
directives européennes nous faisons le
choix de privilégier les mesures mesures
les moins coercitives notamment pour les
familles avec enfants le projet de loi
prévoit donc de renforcer l'assignation
à résidence pour en faire une
alternative à la rétention y compris
pour les personnes qui font l'objet
d'une procédure Dublin pour se faire ce
texte clarifie les condition de l'action
des forces de l'ordre dans le cadre
d'une assignation à résidence et leur
apporte le cadre juridique
nécessaire désormais le texte prévoit
que le dispositif peut également
s'appliquer aux personnes frappées d'une
expulsion adm rative ou judiciaire pour
un motif d'ordre public ou bien aux
personnes qui braveraient l'interdiction
administrative du territoire qui leur
est signifié de telles mesures
concernent avant tout les prêcheurs de
haine et des personnes liées aux
activités de filière terroristes que
nous pourrons ainsi expulser du
territoire dans les meilleurs délais
enfin je veux parler du du sujet
particulièrement complexe qui est celui
du contentieux de la rétention et de
l'éloignement le gouvernement considère
sur ce point très délicat que nous avons
abouti à une solution tout à fait
pertinente et équilibré qui permet de
clarifier les compétences du juge
administratif et du juge judiciaire je
rappelle qu'actuellement le juge des
libertés de la détention et le juge
administratif se prononce tous les deux
sur la rétention le premier sur la
proportionnalité de la mesure le second
sur la légalité ces deux notions sont si
proches l'une de l'autre qu'elles se
confondent en réalité très largement dès
lors nous proposons que le juge des
libertés et de la détention est à
connaître de la rétention quoi de plus
normal qu'un juge judiciaire gardien des
libertés statut à la fois sur la
légalité et la proportionnalité d'une
mesure privative de liberté le juge
administratif conserve bien sûr sa place
il statue quant à lui sur la légalité de
la mesure administrative d'éloignement
cette clarification était indispensable
et elle nous permettra de gagner en
efficacité le texte prévoit que le juge
des libertés et de la détention se
prononce sur la rétention après 48 he
comme c'était le cas avant la loi de
2011 ne fasse passer ce délai à 5 jours
il est indispensable que la personne en
rétention puisse voir un juge avant
d'être le cas échéant éloigné c'est
ainsi et pas autrement que nous
respecterons le droit sans pour autant
céder sur nos objectifs
d'efficacité enfin une exigence de
transparence s'impose à nous les
français ont le droit d'être informés de
ce qui se passe dans les centres de
rétention les associations les
parlementaires le contrôleur général des
lieux de privation de liberté le
Défenseur des droits ne doivent pas être
les seuls à pouvoir y pénétrer c'est la
raison pour laquelle le projet de loi
prévoit un régime juridique spécifique
encadrant l'accès des journalistes au
centre de rétention mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs grâce à ce
projet nous réformons en profondeur le
droit des étrangers et par la même nous
rend rendons notre politique
d'immigration à la fois plus efficace et
plus conforme au principes de la
République c'est la raison pour laquelle
le gouvernement regrette que vous
déposiez une motion de rejet préalable
dont l'unique effet sera de priver le
Sénat d'un nouvel examen du projet de
loi dans quelques instants le rapporteur
de la motion prendra la parole pour
justifier le dépôt de cette motion je
lui répondrai ensuite sur les mesures
adoptées par le Sénat en première
lecture conservé par l'Assemblée
nationale en nouvelle lecture je vous
remercie merci Madame la Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur François Noël
buffet rapporteur de la commission des
lois vous avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteurur monsieur le Président
Madame le ministre mes chers collègues
quelques observations au moment où ce
texte revient devant le
Sénat après la commission mixte
paritaire et malheureusement après avoir
constaté l'échec de cette
commission je voudrais peut-être
réexpliquer le cheminement et la
position du Sénat dans ce
texte tout d'abord rappeler un premier
point c'est que le Sénat au moment où il
a étudié ce texte a fait le choix de
proposer des solutions alternatives à
celles qui ont été proposé par
l'Assemblée nationale pour répondre à un
objectif qui était celui d'avoir un
texte le droit des étrangers qui soit un
texte sérieux qui permettent à la fois
d'accueillir correctement ceux qui
veulent souhaitent venir sur notre
territoire mais en même temps d'être
d'une fermeté absolue à l'égard de ceux
qui venaientent de façon irrégulière
afin qu'ils soitent éloignés nous avons
souhaité le maintien du régime du
conteneux actuel des décisions de
placement en rétention et non pas la
modification que le gouvernement propose
avec l'intervention du juge des libertés
à partir de 5 jours c'est la révision de
2011 que l'on souhaitait garder qui a
montré son efficacité nous avons fixé
les conditions de délivrance de titre de
séjour en maintenant tout d'abord au
préfet la possibilité de délivrer un
titre de séjour ou de ne pas le délivré
c'est-à-dire en contestant le principe
d'une délivrance de plein droit de la
part du préfet de titre de séjour nous
avons aussi voulu maintenir les
conditions pour délivrer un titre de
séjour aux étrangers malades considérant
que le dispositif actu permettant
d'attribuer ce titre de séjour lorsque
le soin existe dans le pays d'origine et
non pas lorsque comme le veut le texte
aujourd'hui il y est un caractère
effectif car nous les services nous ont
dit très clairement que ce serait
difficile de pouvoir apprécier le
caractère effectif de la de l'existence
de ce soin et que la conséquence directe
était qu'en réalité finalement il
suffirait de demander quasiment pour
obtenir le maintien des conditions
actuelles aussi un encadrement pardon
plus strict du séjour de la carte
plurriannuelle en revenant venant sur le
principe comme quoi la carte est
automatiquement de 4 ans en indiquant
qu'elle devait être par principe d'une
année et ensuite effectivement que l'on
pouvait délivrer un titre de séjour de
plus d'une année enfin en revoyant et en
refixant les conditions du regroupement
familial parce que c'était un sujet
extrêmement important sans que son
principe soit remis en cause qu'à tout
le moins les conditions de ce
regroupement soient beaucoup plus
strictes voilà la première étape du
travail du Sénat la deuxième étape c'est
que nous avons essayé Madame le Ministre
à l'occasion de ce débat de rechercher
des amélioration dans le dispositif qui
était proposé nous avons proposé
d'améliorer l'efficacité des mesures
d'éloignement et notamment en ce qui
concerne la procédure des obligations de
quitter le territoire vous avez proposé
un dispositif à caractère général nous
avons proposé un dispositif ciblé
notamment sur les déboutés du droit
d'asile parce qu'ils étaient en 2014
plus de 50000 et que les tribunaux nous
avaient dit avec précision que si la
mesure voulaitt efficace il fallait
impérativement que l'on ait un axe
précis et une cible précise c'est le
choix que que nous avions fait nous
avons souhaité raccourcir les délais en
conformité avec la directive retour pour
permettre l'efficacité du dispositif
d'éloignement je rappelle que c'est un
délet de départ volontaire de 7 jours au
lieu de 30 aujourd'hui et que c'est une
interdiction de retour que nous avons
porté à 5 ans au lieu des 3 ans
aujourd'hui nous avons proposé de
renforcer les modalités d'assignation à
résidence que vous avez proposé
notamment par deux moyens avec un
système de cautionnement et avec la
possibilité d' une attestation déposée
par le maire qui permett de sécuriser le
principe de l'assignation à résidence
puisque vous souhatiez quelle est la
faveur des décisions des tribunaux
plutôt que celle du centre de rétention
ces deux conditions on été rajoutées par
le Sénat nous avons enfin souhaiter la
nécessité de clarifier certaines
dispositions je voudrais pas aller trop
dans le détail sur les précisions
relatives au titre pluannuel de séjour
la revalorisation du contrat d'accueil
et d'intégration qui part un petit peu
dans tous les sens et dans laquelle nous
considérons que le point majeur celui
qui donne au rassemblé c'est d'abord
celui de la connaissance de la langue et
c'est ce point de vue que le Sénat a
souhaité défendre à l'occasion de euh
l'analyse du texte enfin nous avons
encadré la procédure d'accès des
journalistes au centre des retentions
administratives et nous avons supprimé
des dispositions relative à la
nationalité j'insiste sur ce point parce
que nous avions considéré au début du
texte de façon collective j'allais
presque presque dire sur tous les bands
de l'Assemblée ou du Parlement que la
nationalité n'était pas le sujet de ce
texte et qu'il ne fallait donc pas
l'évoquer et c'est dans ces conditions
là que nous
avions rejeté l'ensemble de ces demandes
j'y reviendrai parce que c'est a une
importance par rapport au TEX qui vient
de l'Assemblée nationale le deuxième
point qui me paraît important le
deuxième grand point c'est que le retour
de l' après cette commission mixte
paritaire l'Assemblée nationale n'a rien
retenu de ce que le Sénat avait proposé
strictement rien y compris d'ailleurs
des mesures réglementaires qui avait été
notre souhait et pour lequel on pouvait
espérer qu'elle soit retenue par
l'Assemblée nationale je dois dire sans
confidence particulière devant le Sénat
que les débats qui ont eu lieu préalable
à cette CMP avec le rapporteur de
l'Assemblée nationale avait laissé
entendre que quelqu quelques espoirs
étaient possible sur un certain nombre
de points de caractère réglementaire
mais également sur des points
d'amélioration que je viens de citer et
bien force de constater que les
espérances voir peut-être les signes
positifs qui avaient été donnés n'ont
pas été suivis des fait et que
l'assemblée n'a rien retenu du tout du
travail que nous avions fait je ne parle
pas évidemment d'autres sujets que nous
avions souhaité en particulier la
modification de l'aide médicale d'État
sa transformation en aide médicale
d'urgence donc l'assemblée a décidé de
balayer d'un renvers de manche le
travail du Sénat mais l'assemblée ne
s'est pas contenté de cela puisque elle
a rajouté plusieurs dispositions
nouvelles lors de la lecture lors de sa
lors de sa lecture pardon et notamment
sur proposition du gouvernement selon je
rappelle que selon la jurisprudence du
Conseil constitutionnel dans
l'application des dispositions de
l'article 45 de la Constitution les
amendements adoptés après la commission
mixte paritaire doivent être en relation
directe avec une disposition du texte
encore en discussion ou justifié par la
nécessité de coordonner des dispositions
avec d'autres textes discussion au
Parlement ou permettre le respect de la
Constitution ou corriger une erreur
matérielle je m'interroge très
sérieusement devant vous cet après-midi
sur la conséquence de la conformité à la
Constitution de trois dispositions qui
ont été introduites par les députés à
l'occasion de la nouvelle lecture le
premier point c'est l'ouverture aux
étrangers du service civique en séance
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté un
amendement du Gouvernement modifiant le
Code du service national afin d'élargir
les possibilités pour les étrangers
d'accéder au servicees Civic sous
couverte de clarification de
coordination C cet amendement comporte
un sujet nouveau abordé pour la première
fois dans le cadre de ce texte c'est le
premier point le deuxième point qui a
été rajouté c'est la suppression de
l'assignation à résidence sous
surveillance électronique les députés
ont supprimé la signignation en
résidence sous surveillance électronique
qui était prévu par par les textes
évidment par le CESEDA en particulier
naturellement ces dispositions on été
créées par la loi du 26 juin 2011 ont
pour objet de permettre au juges
d'assigner à résidence à l' étranger
parent d'un enfant mineur ne disposant
pas de garantie de représentation en le
soumettant à cette mesure avantage de la
mesure on place pas en rétention j'ai
cru comprendre que c'était la
philosophie du texte de ne pas placer en
rétention et de privilégier la rétention
au motif que la suppression de ces
dispositions législatives en raison on a
supprimé plutôt on a justifié pardon je
vais trop vite la suppression de cette
disposition en raison de l'absence de
texte réglementaire d'application et en
raison de l'absence oui des textes
réglementaires d'application et que c
deux sur crois cette mesure était
critiable voilà en et puis le trème
point des nouvelles dispositions qui ont
été relatives à l'asile alors ça c'est
intéressant aussi puisque à l'article 29
de coordination le gouvernement a
introduit en séance public la faculté
pour l'autorité administrative d'opposer
l'irrecevabilité à une demande d'asile
formulée en rétention au-delà des 5
premiers jours de celle-ci outre que la
question de l'exercice du droit d'asile
n'avait pas été abordée lors d'examen de
ce texte en première lecture je rappelle
que cette disposition introduit une
dérogation au principe affirmé dans la
dans le dernier texte qui sort de notre
Parlement du 25 juin dernier selon
laquelle seul seul l'OFPRA l'ofice
français de protection des réfugiés et
zapatride peut opposer l'irrecevabilité
à une demande d'asile ce que nous avions
fait il y a 6 mois a été à la faveur
d'un amendement après CMP à l'Assemblée
nationale
détcoté voilà la réalité du texte et
voilà comment il arrive aujourd'hui
devant le Sénat et en commission la
semaine dernière et je renouvelle à
cette tribune la demande je propose que
la question préalable soit discutée
qu'elle soit naturellement votée car à
l'évidence et je le dis avec beaucoup de
sincérité nous avons en première lecture
fait le maximum de travail pour essayer
de converger même si on peut considérer
qu'il y avait des points de vues
différents sur des philosophies
différentes par rapport à ceux qui
étaient les nôtres que les promesses
faites en tous les cas les engagements
non formels certes fait à l'occasion de
la CMP n'ont pas été tenu et queil y a
un moment où trop c'est trop et il faut
savoir s'arrêter que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je demande au Sénat de voter la
question préalable merci merci monsieur
le
rapporteur dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Pierre Yve clomba pour le
groupe
RDSE vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue bien monsieur président madame
la ministre chers collègues cette
discussion générale comme vous le savez
devant selon toute probabilité ce
conclure par l'adoption de la question
préalable je vous épargnerai une analyse
comparative des vertus et des limites
respectives du texte de l'Assemblée
nationale et de son double sénatorial
double sénatorial que dans sa grande
majorité je le rappelle notre groupe
n'avait pas voté en première lecture
n'avit pas voté parce que loin
d'améliorer le projet de loi du
gouvernement qui déjà n'avait pas osé
aller au bout de sa logique le texte du
Sénat non seulement restreignait encore
la portée mais l'orientait dans une
autre direction d'un projet de loi
relatif au droit des étrangers en France
nous étions passés à un projet de loi
portant diverses dispositions relatives
à la maîtrise de l'immigration ce qui
renvoyait à des problématiques
différentes même si elle pouvait
s'accorder sur un certain nombre de
mesures communes d'un côté une logique
intégration de l'autre une logique de
contrôle la première part du principe
que l'immigration est plutôt quelque
chose de positif pour le pays et
d'autant plus qu'elle sera encadrée par
une politique active d'intégration la
seconde que l'immigration est plutôt une
source de problème et d'ennui dont il
s'agit de se protéger en réduisant les
conditions d'accès à notre territoire et
en activant les dispositifs d'expulsion
des indésirables en mettant ces logiques
en exerg je sais et je voiséaction de
mes collègues je sais que je force le
trait je sais que je passe sous silence
que les deux textes tentaient aussi une
certaine nombre de conciliations mais
avouez que les dosages étaient si
différents que les ressemblances avaient
disparu pas étonnant donc que la
commission mixte paritaire se soit
terminée par un constat d'échec pourtant
la question n'est pas de savoir qui a
tort et qui a raison ce que ni le texte
de la l'Assemblée nationale ni celui du
Sénat ne c'est que pardon le problème
c'est que ni le texte de l'Assemblée
nationale ni celui du Sénat ne répond au
problèm de fond et à l'urgence du moment
le projet de loi initiale quelle que
soit sa version doit être le 75e ou 77e
révision des lois de révision des lois
sur l'immigration l'immigration que je
qualifierais
d'ordinaire qui ne pose aucun problème
réel vu la stabilité des flux quelques
240000 entrées annuelles pour 100000
sorties vu aussi l'origine des
demandeurs essentiellement des
ressortissants des pays de l'ancien
empire colonial français ce qu'on
tendance d'ailleurs à oublier souvent
les exartisans de l'intégration des
départements Français d'Algérie à la
France ce qui par contre pose un
redoutable problème c'est l'afflux des
réfugiés chassés par la déstabilisation
du Moyen-Orient et de l'Afrique chass
par la misère du sous-développement
partout dans le monde pour parler
seulement de de l'tiv de l'actualité et
de du voyage de la délégation de la
commission des lois qui vient de se
rendre en Grèce et bien on peut
constater que le problème est d'une
grande ampleur le phénomène est une
grande ampleur un seul chiffre en 2015
911000 entré de migrants syriens
irakiens afghans pakistanais voire en
provenance du Maghreb
uniquement en Suède quasiment 1
million certains jours certains jours du
mois d'aût 10000 10000 10000 réfugiés en
mer
ég jusque là c'était l'Italie qui était
la première en première ligne maintenant
c'est la Grèce
alors ce qui est ce qu'on a pu constater
et qui est heureux c'est que la réponse
la réponse humanitaire est à la hauteur
du problème à la hauteur de ce qu'on
peut attendre d'une Europe qui se dit
civilisée cela grâce à la mobilisation
des Grecs et des organisations
humanitaires grâce à l'aide bien
tempérée quand même des institutions
européennes mais pour le reste pour le
reste et c'est là-dessus que je voudrais
conclure une fois ces réfugiés restaurés
réconfortés soignés identifiés et mis en
fiche une fois ceux qui ont toutes les
chances de bénéficier de l'asile parce
que ressortissant de pays où leur vie
est menacée une fois ceci distingué des
migrants économiques à quelques
centaines près à quelques centaines prês
bien tous se retrouve dans la nature
l'essentiel en route vers l'Allemagne
vers la Suède Suède vers la
Grande-Bretagne très peu vers la France
d'ailleurs et sous ça via les Balcans
pour l'heure ils ne font que transiter
vers des pays prêts à les accueillir ou
du moins qui font comme si mais que se
passera-t-il quand ce ne sera plus le
cas on voit déjà sur l'exemple de calis
et les côtes de la Mer du Nord les
résultats de cette politique du chacun
pour soi à la grâce du sort quand
sera-t-il demain quand les portes de
l'Eldorado se
fermeront autant dire que les débats sur
le bon dosage entre mesures
d'intégration et mesure d'interdiction
et de contrôle laisse une impression
d'irréalité totale le problème essentiel
les problèmes essentiels sont ailleurs
que là où on va les chercher les
solutions aussi c'est la raison pour
laquelle le le groupe RDSE s'abstiendra
sur la question préalable tout en
déplorant que le vrai débat soit encore
reculé et plus encore les décisions
qu'impos la gravité de notre situation
je vous remercie merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Michel Mercier
pour le groupe udi
UC monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues sommes donc appelés ce
soir à discuter après l'échec de la
commission mixte paritaire et du projet
de loi sur le droit des
étrangers c'est bien sûr lors de la
première lecture devant l'Assemblée
nationale et de la première lecture
devant le Sénat qui a lieu le débat de
fond et qu'est-ce qui a euh opposé les
deux assemblées qu'est-ce qui les a
distingué c'est un certain nombre de
choses plusieurs mais une chose
essentielle qui est celle de la
pérennité et des titres de séjour qui me
semble être la mesure
phare qui a été votée par l'Assemblée
nationale et qui permet de donner une
carte de titre de séjour pour 4 ans de
plein droit alors que le Sénat a
souhaité
conservver pour l'autorité
administrative la possibilité de
vérifier chaque année que les conditions
d'octroi de la carte de séjour demeurit
il là un débat qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas qui est un beau débat et qui a été
tranché différemment dans chacune des
deux Chambres du
Parlement la commission mixte paritaire
n'est pas parvenue à trouver un accord
il est tout à fait normal que
qu'aujourd'hui aucun accord ne puisse
être trouvé puisque le même sujet qui a
opposé les deux assemblées demeure
dans dans sa conception même et que on
aille vers la question préalable alors
on peut chercher un certain nombre de
détails c'est vrai que l'Assemblée
nationale a retenu quelques amendements
votés par le Sénat mais ces amendements
du Sénat portaient sur des mesures qui
étaient déjà introduites par l'Assemblée
nationale et c'éta essentiellement des
amendements peut-être pas complètement
rédactionnels mais de précision
d'amélioration de la rédaction on peut
donc dire que les deux textes sont ont
vécu leur vie étranger l'un à l'autre et
que le bicamérisme qui est le nôtre
depuis 1958 fait que même si on peut le
regretter sur ce point l'Assemblée
nationale à le dernier mot elle la
tranché l'URE de la deuxè la lecture
après la commission mixte paritaire nous
nous pensons et nous continuerons à
penser que dans les périodes que nous
vivons il ne faut pas désarmer
l'autorité administrative il faut lui
laisser la possibilité de vérifier
chaque année que la situation des
personnes étrangères reste bien
conforme à la loi et que il y a rien là
qui soit infamment pour les personnes
étrangères il y a rien là qui empêche
leur intégration c'est une vérification
normale par l'autorité administrative de
la situation de droit dans laquelle elle
se trouve et donc l'Assemblée nationale
a choisi une autre voie nous ne pouvons
pas la suivre sur ce point c'est la
raison pour laquelle notre groupe suivra
le rapporteur en votant la question
préalable merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Ilian assassie pour
le groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen vous avez la la parole ma cher
collègue monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues lors de la
première lecture de ce texte le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen était
auteur d'une motion tendant à opposer la
question
préalable afin que soit rejeté
l'ensemble du projet de loi la version
revue par la droite sénatoriale a été
rejeté par les députés car elle aggravé
la précarité de la situation des
étrangers en situation irrégulière et
réorienté les disposition sur la
maîtrise de l'immigration irrégulière en
renforçant des dispositifs de contrôle
tout en facilitant l'éloignement le
texte initial du gouvernement était et
demeure euh en tout cas c'est ce que
nous pensons en encore aujourd'hui était
et demeure donc loin d'être ambitieux si
des collègues sur les bancs du groupe
socialiste ont affirmé avec raison que
je cite la droite sénatoriale court
après l'extrême droite en amalgamant
réfugiés et immigrés en voulant faire
des étrangers des bouqu émissaires fin
de citation il ne faut pas manquer ce
n'est qu'une citation monsieur caoci
hein il ne faut pas manquer de relever
que les mêmes qui on d'autres temps
s'étit élevés contre la loi la son de
2011 laisse place aujourd'hui au
parachèvement de cette loi avec cette
nouvelle lecture nous nous retrouvons
dans une situation comparable à ce C
près que la droite sénatoriale a
considéré donc inutile de délibérer une
nouvelle fois sur ce projet de loi
contte tenu des nombreus divergenence
avec l'Assemblée nationale et et le
gouvernement alors selon vous monsieur
le rapporteur je cite si de nombreux
désaccords entre l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat ont conduit les les députés
à revenir sur un grand nombre de choix
opérés par le Sénat plusieurs
disposition adopté auraiit pu donner
lieu à un accord notamment l'extension
de la durée d'interdiction de retour à 5
ans au lieu de 3 ans pour notre part il
va s'en dire que nous ne sommes pas
mécontents du rejet par les députés de
mesures aggravantes et sécuritaires
inscrit dans ce texte par votre
majorité concernant par exemple l'aide
médicale aux étrangers ou encore les
facilité d'éloignement par ailleurs
madame la ministre nous saluons la
modification qui a été apporté par le
gouvernement qui vise à élargir les
possibilités pour les étrangers
d'accéder au servicees Civic même si je
considère moi aussi que cette mesure
aurait pu être portée par un autre
véhicule que celui-ci mais bon en
revanche la majorité de l'Assemblée
nationale s'est bien gardé de revenir
sur le principe de surveillance
permanente que met en place ce projet de
loi déjà soumise à un dédal d'obligation
de vérification et de production de
preuves l'obtention d'un titre de séjour
pourra maintenant être remise en cause à
tout instant créant finalement un climat
de doute sur la sincérité de la
situation des potentiels fraudeur les
articles 8 et 25 n nous proposerons de
nouveau la su la suppression si la
question préalable n'était pas adopté
mais j'ai des doutes donc les articles 8
et 25 créent en effet les conditions de
ces contrôles avec la levée inédite du
secret professionnel pour plusieurs
organismes et leur personnel Paul emploi
les écoles et les universités les
établissements de santé publ et privé
les fournisseurs d'énergie et opérateurs
de téléphonie tout comme les
établissements bancaires auront
désormais l'obligation sous peine
d'amende de fournir toute information
que les agents de la préfecture jugeront
utile pour contrôler la sincérité et
l'exactitude des déclarations et de
l'authenticité des pièces des personnes
titulaires d'unune carte de séjour je ne
commmente pas enfin je ne reviendrai pas
sur l'ensemble des dispositifs que
propose ce projet de loi nous les avons
déjà vertement critiqué et nos
propositions ont déjà été doctement
battu en brèche en première lecture mais
en définitive dans la continuité des
réformes passées sur le sujet le
gouvernement a souité a souhaité
maintenir l'inversion de la logique
d'intégration affirmant que les
personnes étrangères ont besoin de droit
pour s'intégrer et non de s'intégrer
pour mériter des droits l'immigration
autorisée entre guillemets étant ainsi
maintenue dans une situation
administrative précaire qui empêche
celles et ceux qu'ell concerne de
trouver toute leur place en France
monsieur le rapporteur vous dénoncez la
position laxiste de l'Assemblée
nationale et l'aveuglement du
gouvernement sur les questions
migratoires pourtant des récentes
déclarations du Premier ministre lors
d'une conférence sur la sécurité à
Munich devrait monsieur le rapporteur
vous rassurer quand il estime bon selon
ses propres termes de je cite faire
passer un message d'efficacité et de
fermeté assinant que je cite encore
l'Europe ne peut accueillir davantage de
réfugiés il ne s'agit pas là de discuter
du droit d'asile encore que ni même du
dispositif d'accueil des réfugiés sur
lequels nous reviendrons le 1er mars
prochain lors du débat consacré au sein
de notre haute assemblée mais vous
m'excuserez les propos sont quand même
assez édifiants outre qu'ils sont quand
même révélateurs d'un glissement
politique certain ils sont de nature à
pour une Europe fermée sur elle-même et
qui érie en dogme la peur du monde la
peur des mouvements du monde et ce au
nom de sa protection et de sa sécurité
c'est ainsi par exemple que le Parlement
danois vient d'adopter à une écrasante
majorité un projet de loi sur
l'immigration dont plusieurs mesures
scandaleuses nous ont heurté comme elles
ont heurté tous les défenseurs des
droits de l'Homme teles que la mesure
sur la confiscation d'une partie des
biens des migrants il est raisonnable
que l'État ne pe pas pour ceux qui
peuvent le faire par eux-mêmes a fait
valoir le ministre de l'Intégration la
ministre de l'Intégration danoise il
s'agit d'un disposit d'un dispositif
contraire aux standards européens et
internationaux de protection des droits
de l'homme c'est indigné le Haut
Commissariat au réfugiés de l'ONU ces
dérives identitaires ces égoïsmes
nationaux tout droit issu de l'ordre
économique mondial établi ne sont pas
dignes de notre vieux continent ne sont
pas dignes de notre République madame la
ministre mesieur chers collègues ce
projet de société mais vous le savez
n'est pas le nôtre c'est par la
différence et dans le divers que
s'exalte l'existence j'ose encore croire
Madame la Ministre que l'essence de ces
mots du poète breton Victor Segalen
puisse alléger le climat lourd des
craintes et des replis identitaires NAS
et à Bond qui sévissent ces temps-ci
pour conclure et vous l'aurez compris
les sénatrices et les sénateurs du
groupe CRC s'opposeront de nouveau à ce
projet de loi qui ne ront pas avec la
logique répressive et suspicieuse du
gouvernement précédent merci ma cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Jean
Yve Lecomte pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues pour
préciser d'abord nous parlons ici du
droit qui s'applique aux étrangers qui
séjournent légalement sur notre
territoire et pas de l'accueil des
réfugiés ce sont deux choses différentes
j'ajouteraiis que la réforme qui nous
est proposée est une réforme absolument
indispensable attendu depuis longtemps
et qui permet des des améliorations au
droits des étrangers qu'il convient de
rappeler et Don dont il convient de se
féliciter je compléterai en en
soulignant quelques regrets et et
quelques difficultés soulevées par des
nouvelles dispositions ajoutées à
l'Assemblée nationale d'abord c'est une
réforme attendue et indispensable du cza
qui comporte plusieurs améliorations
d'abord et objectif d'abord sécuriser le
parcours d'intégration des
ressortissants étrangers deuxièmement
contribuer à l'attractivité de la France
en créant une carte propre au talents
internationaux et en simplifiant le
parcours des étudiants étrangers enfin
garantir la protuction des liberté
individuelle et l'efficacité des
décisions administratives d'éloignement
s'agissant des séjours irréguliers le
titre de séjour pluriannuel est
effectivement une réelle avancée
puisqu'il assure la pérennité du séjour
et permet aux étrangers de se projeter
dans l'avenir avec davantage de sérénité
il invite aussi certaines il évite aussi
certaines difficultés rencontrées par
les titulaires d'un titre temporaire
d'une durée de validité d'un an en
particulier pour les logements ou bien
faire par exemple un emprunt immobilier
enfin toute toute obstacle finalement à
l'intégration enfin il est une solution
pragmatique à l'engorgement des services
préfectoraux pour les renouvellements
dont certains sont alors que certaines
préfectures sont surchargées de demande
et euh ne peut pas ne peuvent pas
accueillir dans un délai et dans un dans
de conditions décente les ressortissants
étrangers rappelons que dans certaines
préfectures ou sous-préfectures c'est
des fils d'attente dès 3h du matin qui
se forme sans aucune garantie pour les
personnes qui font la queue d'être reçu
lors de la journée suivante on ne peut
donc que se féliciter que le
gouvernement ait pris en main cette
réelle difficulté des étrangers en
France car intégrer c'est aussi
simplifier
il faut se féliciter que l'attribution
de plein droit de la carte de résident
pour les familles de français puisse
être une réalité j'ajouterait que pour
souligner tout tout ce qui a été fait
pour ajouter à l'attractivité de la
France pour les étudiants et les
investisseurs étrangers mais là j'ai une
petite question parce que les visas
biométriques qui sont imposés sont
parfois pour les titres pour les visas
qui vaut va le titre de séjour pour les
étudiants et les investisseurs étrangers
sont parfois une difficulté dans les
grands pays où il y a qu'un seul seul
poste consulaire et je crois que puisque
la c'est une compétence nationale que
nous qui qui qui existe pour les visas
long séjour il faudrait supprimer
l'exigence de biométrie dans un certain
nombre de pays et ça je je m'adresse à
vous madame la ministre car je pense à
des pays comme le Japon où les
déplacements sont très difficiles enfin
très coûteux au Brésil où les
déplacements sont très difficiles et où
il est important de de de renforcer
notre attractivité en en en supprimant
cette exigence de biométrie pour les
vill Villons ce jours pour les étudiants
enfin le le le toutefois le le projet de
loi méritait quand même des discussions
sur un certain nombre de points certains
amendements avaient été discutés en
première lecture je rappelle ce qui
était du domaine et qui qui ne pourront
pas être abordés probablement puisque la
majorité est elle qu qu'une question
préalable sera votée sur ce qui se
passera pour les détenteurs de CDD d'une
durée égale ou supérieure à 12 mois qui
resteront travailleurs temporaires
plutôt que d'avoir une carte de séjour
salarié le le le droit des étrangers
malades mériterait encore d'être
renforcé et nous l'avions nous avions
fait quelques propositions lors du de de
la première lecture de la même manière
que
l'alignement le le le le fait de
sanctionner un étranger qui ne se se
rendrait pas à une convocation sans sans
motif légitime et qui pourrait se
trouver en situation irrégulière si euh
euh parce que une convocation ce motif
légitime lui permettrait de d'être
conduirait à être sanctionné enfin le
porter à à 2 jours ouvrés au lieu de 48
he le délai de recours contre les TF
sans délai de départ volontaire et les
assignations de résidence prononcé pour
une durée de 45 jours renouvelable afin
d'améliorer la mise en œuvre effective
de ce droit notamment durant les weekend
j'avais aussi à titre personnel présenté
un certain nombre d'amendement sur une
carte de résident permanent après 15 ans
de présence régulière sur le territoire
et sur l'interdiction totale de de la de
rétention des des des mineurs encras euh
j'avais aussi euh déposé une série
d'amendements sur euh euh les titres de
séjour des jeunes placés à l'aide
sociale à l'enfance le gouvernement
avait donné un avis défavorable au motif
qu'une instruction interministériel
était en cours euh or ceci s'est conclu
par la circulaire du 25 janvier 2016 qui
euh malheureusement ne résout pas
l'ensemble des problèmes de ces jeunes
et euh la circulaire n'est évidemment
pas opposable devant le tribunal
administratif et nous risquons de
constater encore des difficultés
d'application et des applications
disparates sur le territoire et je vous
demanderai madame la ministre de bien
vouloir regarder à nouveau un certain
nombre de ces dispositions parce que la
la circulire actuelle ne répond pas à
l'ensemble des enjeux en particulier
pour euh les demandes d'autorisation de
travail à la directe qui peuvent être
très compliqués pour euh les mineurs
dans ces
situations je regrette aussi un certain
nombre de dispositions nouvelles qui ont
été introduites à l'Assemblée nationale
euh euh notre rapporteur a évoqué celle
sur le l'asile je soulignerai aussi
celle qui souligne qui qui qui permet de
le recours aux forces de police et de
gendarmerie pour les étrangers non
assignés à résidence sans relation
directe et et qui et sont sans relation
directe avec les dispositions qui
avaient été jusque-là en discussion dans
le projet de loi et qui ont été
introduite en 2e lecture par surprise et
enfin vous l'avez souligné une
disposition qui s'agissant du droit
d'asile permet à l'OFPRA évite donne à
l'autorité administrative une compétence
que jusque-là seul l'OFPRA avait
concernant la recevabilité d'une demande
d'asile et en particulier les
dispositions qui ont été insérées à
l'alinéa 10 et 11 de l'article 29 qui
porte gravement atteinte au principe de
l'exclusivité du rôle de l'OFPRA dans ce
domaine à l'équilibre qui avait été pris
et choisi euh ici euh au Sénat euh en
pour entre le rôle de l'autorité
administrative et l'OFPRA pour décider
de ces cas-là et il est dommage que la
disposition qui était intégrée en 2e
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale semble
non direct contraire à la directive et
n'avait pas été discuté lors de la
réforme de l'asile en janvier et en en
juin et juillet dernier il est
regrettable que cette disposition a été
introduite vous l'avez souligné monsieur
le rapporteur et je regrette que je
regrette que la motion
préalable je je regrette que la MO
préalable ne nous permettent pas de
revenir dessus parce
qu'effectivement en conclusion je dirais
et c'est finalement l'esprit de cette
réforme il n'y a pas d'intégration sans
égalité des droits il n'y a pas
d'intégration sans égalité des droits et
c'est la raison pour laquelle tout ce
qui a été la carte de séjour pluriannuel
les simplifications sont absolument
indispensables pour mieux intégrer il
était aussi indispensable et vous l'avez
retiré au Sénat en première lecture et
vous réaffirmez ce principe alors que
nous à gauche nous affirmons que dans
des situations précises c'estes deux
plein droit qu'un certain nombre de
droits doivent être reconnus vous
considérez et Monsieur Mercier l'a
encore rappelé que finalement il faut
laisser la compétence de l'autorité
administrative décider du OUI ou du non
mais comment il faudrait que les les
droits ne soient pas les mêmes sur
l'ensemble du territoire nous disons à
gauche qu'il convient que les droits
soient les mêmes pour tous et lorsque
les les une situation donne un plein
droit il faut que ce soit respecté vous
avez parlé des quotas vous avez mis en
place des cotas mon tout à fait je je je
je m'achemine rapidement vers la
conclusion vous avez mis en place des
quotas ces quotas sont le contraire d'un
respect des droits c'est une provocation
par rapport à ce au texte de l'Assemblée
nationale et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il était impossible à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat de
s'accorder sur un texte et finalement en
faisant des provocations sur ce texte en
mettant en place des quotas vous
empêchez au Sénat de faire son travail
et d'améliorer le texte de l'Assemblée
nationale et nous regrettons
profondément nous regrettons
profondément que cette motion préalable
ne nous permette pas de revenir sur le
fond le travail vous l'aviez fait il y a
eu des des provocations avec les quotas
qui ne peuvent pas rester en l'état et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je je je
regrette de devoir constater que nous
sommes en désaccord nous nous devons
travailler sur ce TEX
et V vos provocations de la première
lecture empêche de travailler avec
l'Assemblée
nationale c'est dommage de dépasser le
temps de cette façon c'est autant
d'iresect pour les autres
orateurs bien sûr vous pouvez la parole
est maintenant à Madame est bembassa
pour le groupe écologiste vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui pour examiner en nouvelle
lecture le projet de loi relative au
droits des étrangers en France qui
probablement sera rejeté en l'état en
effet son rapporteur monsieur buffet
proposera au Sénat au nom de notre
commission des lois de décider qu'il n'y
a pas lieu de poursuivre la
délibération argument principal de cette
motion le fait que je cite en nouvelle
lecture le texte adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale n'est pris en compte aucune
des préoccupations majeures exprimé par
le Sénat à travers plusieurs amendements
d'importance rappelons ici que le Sénat
à l'initiative de la droite avait
considérablement durci le texte allant
même jusqu'en charger le titre jusqu'à
en changer le titre et passer de projet
de loi relative au droits des étrangers
en France à projet de loi portant
diverses dispositions relatives à la
maîtrise de
l'immigration tout est dit dans ce titre
dont le texte att trait à des droits
d'individus d'hommes de femmes d'enfants
immigrés auquel la droite sénatoriale
répond par maîtrise de l'immigration la
isation sur ce thème nous l'avons
retrouvé tout au long des débats au sein
de notre haute assemblée qui a fini par
adopter nombre de dispositions pour le
moins problématique limitation de
l'octroit du nouveau titre du de séjour
pluriannuel aux titulaires d'un CDI aux
entrepreneurs et aux personnes exerçant
une une profession libérale et aux
étudiants inscrits en master restriction
des conditions d'accès à l'aide médicale
d'État restriction des conditions du
regroupement familial conditionnement du
du droit au séjour pour raison médical à
l'absence totale de traitement dans le
pays
d'origine même s'il faut bien admettre
que le texte adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale comme le projet de loi
initiale d'ailleurs était très loin de
satisfaire nos attentes son vot tel
qu'el sera un moindre mal nous avions
toutefois au groupe écologiste des
propositions à défendre pour l'améliorer
surtout qu'il comporte encore des
dispositions que nous ne pouvons
cautionner exemple plus emblématique les
articles 8 et 25 qui figurent encore
imposant à une longue liste
d'administration ou d'entreprises
publiques et privées de fournir toute
information
que les agents de la préfecture jugeront
utile pour le contrôle je cite de la
sincérité et de l'exactitude des
déclarations souscrites ou au contrôle
de l'authenticité des pièces bien sûr
des pièces des personnes titulaires
d'une carte de séjour sous peine d'une
amende de
€ ces dispositions ont été ancé par
nombre de professionnels et
d'institutions notamment par la
Commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme qui dénonce je cite
une atteinte disproportionnée au droit à
la vie privée et familiale garantie à
l'article 8 de la Convention européenne
des droits de
l'homme et par le Défenseur des droits
également pour qui en fait il s'agit je
cite de la disposition la plus
contestable du texte autre exemple
d'importance l'article 19 qui en
encadrant la rétention des mineurs
permet la légalisation de cette pratique
indigne de notre pays faut-il rappeler
mes chers collègues que l'enfermement
d'enfants en centre de rétention a déjà
été plusieurs fois considéré par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme comme
un traitement inhumain et dégradant au
sens de l'article 3 de la
CEDH malgré cela en 2014
5692 enfants ont été enfermés 110 en
métropole et
5582 à Mayotte mais de ces dispositions
pas plus que de celles concernant les
étrangers malades ou les conjoints de
français nous n'aurons probablement pas
l'occasion d'en débattre d'avant age je
le regrette ce sont des sujets
importants qui méritent un débat
démocratique mais j'avoue également que
je suis un peu soulagé de ne pas avoir à
revivre les débats auxquels nous avons
assisté en première lecture et qui ont
été surtout l'occasion de posture
parfois relativement
violente nous l'avons oh cher monsieur
vous êtes là c'est bien
nous l'avons constaté ces derniers mois
surtout lorsqu'on parle d'immigration il
est difficile pour certains de raisons
gardé et de résister au discours chargés
d'amalgam avec une tendance à la
diabolisation de
l'étranger les raisons électoralistes
n'échappent pas au grand monde à grand
monde pardon au moins aujourd'hui ces
discours nous seront-ils épargné je vous
remercie ainsi que Monsieur
carucci Merci ma cher collègue et je
donne la parole à Monsieur Roger carouci
pour le les
républicains monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le président de la
commission des
lois naturellement je je partage
pleinement
l'avis du rapporteur qui tout à l'heure
disait qu'un certain nombre de
modifications issues d'amendement du
gouvernement vont tomber sous le coup de
la censure du Conseil constitutionnel
c'est une évidence ça ne correspond pas
ni au texte antérieur ni aux règles en
la matière et donc je pense que déjà le
gouvernement s'est fourvoyé en en
acceptant ou en supportant un certain
nombre de dispositions le deuxième
élément c'est que naturellement et je
partage pleinement l'avis de mon
collègue buffet
franchement on a beaucoup débattu ici du
texte on a beaucoup transformé alors
tout le monde nétait pas d'accord mais
c'est le travail qui est fait en
commission en séance pliniiaire en
travail d'amendement se retrouver avec
un texte totalement dossé et revenant
uniquement à ce queavait voulu faire
l'Assemblée nationale et les amendements
du Gouvernement ça revient nier le rôle
du Sénat alors très bien on va pas
recommencer le débat pour en tout état
de cause voir à la fin de la fin
l'Assemblée nationale ne pas en tenir
compte ça n'a pas de sens et par
conséquent je soutiendrai naturellement
la motion mettant un terme au débat mais
moi je veux dire au
gouvernement qu'il vient de rater un
magnifique
rendez-vous lorsque manuel Vals nous
avait annoncer un texte il était à
l'époque encore ministre de l'intérieur
ça ne gênait personne et en tout cas pas
le ministre de dire que c'est un texte
sur
l'immigration il employait le terme il
l'employait à cette tribune et on
attendait un texte sur
l'immigration ce texte n'est jamais
arrivé ou plus exactement ce qu'on a vu
arriver c'est après des circonvolutions
internes à la gauche un texte
définissant ici ou là et à la marge des
nouveaux droits très limités au niveau
purement administratif ou sur le droit
des étrangers immigration on nen parle
pas comme si le mot était tabou comme si
le sujet était àout mais moi je vais
vous dire ce qui est le pire c'est
justement que le Parlement ne puisse pas
en parler clairement si on veut éviter
non non monsieur cton B ne revenez pas
là-dessus si on veut éviter que ce soit
les fantasmes les excès parlons-en
disons les choses lorsqu'on a fait voter
sincèrement le fait qu'il y a un débat
au Parlement pour éventuellement établir
un certain nombre un quôat d'étrangers
pouvant rentrer sur le territoire
national en quoi est-ce que c'est une
attitude sectaire et raciste c'est
simplement une réalité nous n'avons pas
la même réalité que l'Allemagne nous
n'avons pas la même réalité que
l'Allemagne nous je n' interrompu
personne nous n'avons pas nous n'avons
pas la même réalité que l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne a une situation
démographique a une situation budgétaire
à une situation de l'emploi qui n'est
pas la nôtre donc par définition si on
ne peut même pas évoquer la situation de
la société française de l'économie
française pour dire combien nous pouvons
accepter d'entrant dans quelles
conditions nous sommes capables de les
intégrer dans quelles conditions nous
avons les moyens financiers nous avons
la capacité de faire en sorte qu'il
deviennent des des bons citoyens moi
j'ai toujours protesté contre la
faiblesse des moyens de l'OFI qui fait
en parallèle de l'ofpr un travail
essentiel mais qui a de moins en moins
de crédit pour simplement les l'ensemble
de la formation à la citoyenneté est-ce
que vous croyez que c'est digne de dire
mais non mais non il faut surtout pas
fermer les frontières il faut surtout
pas avoir la moindre attitude il faut
surtout pas avoir le le moindre contrôle
mais enfin une fois qu'ils sont là hein
Ben qui se débrouille parce que par
définition on n' pas les moyens de leur
filer un job on n pas les moyens de leur
donner un logement et d'ailleurs on n'
pas les moyens de les former à la
citoyenneté mais qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire c'est pas ça la République la
République quand on en parle avec le
droit d'asile avec la tradition de
tolérance et d'ouverture c'est une
république qui accepte les étrangers qui
rentrent et qu'ils forment et qu'ils
intègrent à la citoyenneté française si
nous n'en sommes pas capables si nous
n'en avons pas les moyens c'est un
mensonge c'est un mensonge permanent par
rapport à ceux qui rentrent et par
rapport aux citoyens français donc
simplement ce que nous avons dit sur ces
bans c'est simplement ayez une politique
migratoire digne de ce nom contrôler
parce que la France n'a pas aujourd'hui
les moyens de faire en sorte
d'accueillir évidemment massivement mais
au moins ceux qui rentrent
formonsles éduquonsles intégronsles
donnonsleur un logement un emploi sinon
ça n'a pas de sens la véritable
tradition de tolérance d'ouverture de
liberté et d'intégration à la nation
française ce sont ceux qui ici défendent
le fait qu'on ne peut pas massivement
accepter qu'il faut au contraire fixer
un certain nombre de règles parce que si
les gens acceptent ces règles ensuite
ils auront accès à la citoyenneté alors
il y a pas de débat d'un côté de ceux
qui sont des durs des méchants des
fantasmatiques et des de l'autre côté
ceux qui veulent l'ouverture et la
liberté non la liberté la première des
libertés c'est la dignité et elle est de
ce côtél merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur André richichard
pour les
républicains vous avez la parole pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues quelle déception mes chers
collègues quelle déception madame la
ministre que votre majorité et vous-même
n'ayez su entendre une fois de plus la
voix du
Sénat la position du Sénat sur la
question migratoire a toujours été forte
elle est d'autant plus que l'actualité
quotidienne malheureusement nous y
incite rappelonsla elle se résume en tro
points nous souhaitons proposer une
politique juste et équitable pour les
étrangers qui demandent à vivre sur
notre territoire dans la légalité nous
souhaitons combattre l'immigration
régulière nous souhaitons enfin
préserver nos valeurs dans un intérêt
national bien compris dès 2004 la Cour
des comptes avait posé clairement les
enjeux en écrivant j'ouvre les
guillumets la situation d'une bonne
partie des populations issues de
l'immigration la plus récente est plus
que
préoccupante outre qu'elle se traduit
par des situations S indigne elle est à
l'origine directe ou indirecte de
tension sociale et raciale grave lourde
de menaces pour l'avenir depuis la
situation et c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire ne s'est pas amélioré
l'immigration clandestine n'a cessé
d'augmenter même si son évaluation est
complexe on peut l'évaluer en
comptabilisant le nombre de
bénéficiaires de la me rappelons qu'elle
est augmenté de 35 % en 3 ans on peut
l'évaluer aussi en s'appuyant sur le
nombre de députés de débouté du droit
d'asile dont le système est une fabrique
de près de 50000 clandestins
supplémentaires chaque année dans notre
pays mes chers collègues la France ne
peut pas ne doit plus régulariser et
laisser se maintenir sur le territoire
national les personnes qui entrre et qui
demeure
illégalement mais madame la ministre
votre gouvernement refuse de regarder
cette réalité vraiment en face et de
prendre les bonnes mesures lors de la
discussion au Sénat de votre texte nous
avions adopté des positions fortes le
principe des plafonds annuels votés par
le Parlement la transformation de l'Ame
en Amu l'alignement sur les directives
européennes des délais pour le
regroupement familial et les départs
volontaires nous avions aussi fait le
choix de maintenir les équilibres de la
loi relative à l'immigration de 2011
marquant son opposition au titre
pluriannuel de séjour supprimant les cas
de délivrance de certains tites de
séjour et imposant on l'a dit tout à
l'heure l'inexistence de traitement dans
le pays d'origine pour les pour
conserver et recevoir les étrangers
malades pour votre
part le gouvernement et votre majorité
et sa majorité vous êtes situé dans la
continuité des décisions successives qui
ont été prises depuis 2012
d'assouplissement des régularisations de
diminution des critères pour la
naturalisation et même de suppression du
timbre pour les l'aide médicale d'État
d' lors nous n sommes aujourd'hui
confrontés certes on l'a dit tout à
l'heure à deux postures totalement
différents et frontalement opposé la
nôtre que nous avons voulu réaliste et
celle de votre majorité qui a fait le
choix de refuser les plus importantes de
nos propositions on profite donc d'un
échec de la CMP pour rétablir en
définitive les dispositions que
l'Assemblée nationale avait voté en
première lecture que dire en outre des
dispositions nouvelles introduites par
l'Assemblée nationale sans lien direct
avec le texte qui sur un plan
constitutionnel comme l'a dit notre
rapporteur semble plutôt douteux madame
la ministre mes chers collègues nous
pouvons nous contenter d'analyser la
question migratoire sous le seul prisme
des titres de séjours
réguli au demeurant délivré par une
administration
saturée certes la question migratoire
n'est pas franco-française l'Europe
entière connaît ce chaos en 2015
l'Europe a enregistré faut-il le
rappeler 1lion
30000 franchissements illégaux de ces
frontières extérieures ce chiffre
représente plus de six fois celui de
2014 le contrôle aux frontières
extérieures est hélas une fiction
puisque dans les tris/arts des cas on le
sait il n'y a aucune prise d'empreinte
aucune vérification d'identité aucun
criblage dans aucun fichier de police
d'aucune sorte cessons d'ors de croire
que de simples gardes frontières
suffiront à endiguer ces flux issu d'un
département frontalier je mesure bien
bien l'importance de l'ouverture de
l'espace Schengen et son intérêt mais
cela ne peut se faire au prix d'une
gestion voir pire d'une non gestion des
flux qu'il soit réguliers ou irréguliers
madame la ministre je redirait ce qu'on
dit mes collègues de cban tout à l'heure
votre texte ne répond pas aux exigences
du moment c'est pourquoi comme l'a
proposé notre rapporteur je voterai la
question préalable merci mon cher
collègue
la parole est à Madame Éveline yeet pour
le groupe socialiste et républicain pour
6 minutes ma chère
collègue monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers
collègues nous le savons les migrations
seront des enjeux inévitables pour les
décennies à venir même si l'accord de la
COP 21 prévoit une limitation de la
hausse de la température terrestre il
n'en demeure pas moins que les
prévisions internationales restent
inexorables en effet plus de 250
millions d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants
de tous horizons chercheront de nouveaux
lieux de vie dans des territoires
différents et moins impactés un exode
d'une ampleur mondiale qu'aucune
frontière n'
les réfugiés climatiques sont au nombre
de 83 millions entre 2011 et 2014 ils
sont déjà deux fois plus nombreux que
les réfugiés de guerre qui sont au
nombre de 42 pour la même période mais
comme vous le savez dans de récentes
études notamment l'audit parlementaire
il a été démontré que les étrangers
contribuent positivement à l'économie
française au-delà de
l'économie quelle que soit leur
provenance dont nous sommes tous issus
il s'implique aussi dans le monde
associatif et culturel leur présence
nous ouvre sur le monde et à l'ORS où le
repli sur soi est un danger pour notre
pays elle nous rappelle que nous ne
sommes qu'une partie d'un tout monsieur
le ministre et mes chers collègues après
le projet de réforme du droit d'asile
qui permet aujourd'hui à la France
d'étudier un plus grand nombre de
demandes avec un traitement beaucoup
plus rapide même s'il reste encore
certaines améliorations à apporter nous
avons l'occasion de rediscuter d'un
projet de loi droit des étrangers en
France le gouvernement s'est déjà attelé
par deux circulaires des 12 décembre
2012 et 3 janvier 2014 à améliorer
l'accueil de cette population en
préfecture tout d'abord je tiens à
remercier les députés notamment le
rapporteur de la commission des lois à
l'Assemblée nationale d'avoir repris le
titre initial du projet défini par le
gouvernement droit des étrangers en
France au lieu de diverses dispositions
relatives à la maîtrise de l'immigration
sorti de notre bienveillante assemblée
ce projet après le rééquilibrage en
nouvelle lecture par l'Assemblée
nationale à l'image du texte
gouvernemental a permis plusieurs
avancées notamment la création de la
carte de séjour pluriannuel à 4 ans et
la carte de résident permanent par
principe la suppression du passage par
une carte de séjour temporaire pour
obtenir un titre pluriannuel en cas de
changement de motif ou encore
l'encadrement en rétention d'un étranger
accompagné d'un mineur pour ne citer que
ces exemples néanmoins nous aurions
souhaité des améliorations sur plusieurs
axes l'accès à l'AME à la protection
universelle maladie afin d'éviter que
des situations précaires persistent et
demeurent sur le territoire de même pour
la décision du transp de compétences de
l'ARS à l'OFI pour l'évaluation de
l'état de santé des personnes en vue de
l'obtention d'un droit de séjour pour
des raisons médicales de même aussi
l'accès au regroupement familial et à la
carte de résident pour les bénéficiaires
de laallocation adulte cap qui reste
très injuste vis-à-vis d'autres
étrangers de sujets qui ont été
largement évoqués par le défenseur des
droits de même nous aurions souhaité
évoquer la suppression définitive de la
présidence de la présence de mineurs
accompagnés ou non dans les centres de
rétention ou le recours de tests ha ceux
dont la fiabilité est largement remise
en cause par la communauté scientifique
avec une marge d'erreur de 2 ans minimum
entre 16 et 18 ans si son encadrement a
été voter confirme dans ce conforme dans
ce texte il est très probable que nous
en reparlerons prochainement dans le
cadre de la loi de la protection de
l'enfance enfin enfin intervenu entre
deux lectures l'extension apportée à
l'article 18 du recours à la force
publique ne peut nous satisfaire en
l'état des consensus sur quelques points
contriburaient à une plus forte
inclusion dans un grand respect des
hommes et des femmes qui souhaitent
partager leur avenir avec le nôtre
madame la ministre monsieur le président
mes chers collègues même si des points
restent en suspens ù auraient pu être
améliorés ce projet de loi apporte
quelques réponses la majorité
sénatoriale une fois de plus en a décidé
autrement en présentant une question
préalable nous nous y opposerons bien
entendu pour toute ces raisons que j'ai
évoqué il va de soi que nous aurions
souhaité qu'un nouveau débat ait lieu
dans cette enceinte pour permettre de
faire avancer de nouveaux droit en
faveur des étrangers merci ma cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
R pour le groupe les
républicains vous avez la parole mon
cher
collègue monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre monsieurs le rapporteurs mes
chers
collègues la nouvelle lecture du projet
de loi relative au droits des étrangers
témoigne l'ampleur des difficulté
d'intégration que rencontre notre pays
et de l'urgence à trouver de solutions
pérenes pour indiguer les vagues
d'migration qui frappe la
France la situation des étrangers à
mayott dont la plupart se trouve dans
l'irrégularité appelle quelques
observations de ma part tant elle ne
laisse plus personne
indifférente un récent rapport de la
Cour de Comptes publié il y a exactement
4 semaines intitulé Le la
départementalisation de Mayotte une
réforme mal préparée des actions
prioritaire à conduire nous rappelle
l'urgence qui règne dans ce
territoire ce titre lance une fois de
plus une alerte au Parlement souverain
pour légiférer à l'aide de des
dispositifs adaptés aux réalités
locales ainsi la cour insiste sur l'état
d'impréparation législative dans lequel
se trouve le département pour recevoir
des nouvelles compétences et appel avant
toute autre action à une définition
claire des étapes à franchir pour une
départementalisation réussie ainsi qu'à
un effort énergique pour combler le
retard dans un esprit de responsabilité
est partagé entre le Département et
l'État l'accueil et l'intégration des
étrangers font partie de ces actions
dont la la gestion relève plus de la
coresponsabilité l'ordonnance du 7 mai
2014 qui étant à Mayotte la CCDA ne fait
qu'apporter des ajustements techniques
pour y rendre applicable le droit
européen conformément à la loi du 20
novembre
2012 lors de la première discussion de
ce même texte j'ai eu à présenter un
amendement en ce sens à l'article 26 du
projet et je regrette qu'il soit rejeté
par la Commission des loi le constat
global de la départementisation de
Mayotte se traduit par un échec des
mesures inappropriées pour aligner
Mayotte sur le droit commun et la cour
vient de le rappeler à nouveau or nous
savons qu'il existe des outils de
coopération avec les Comores qui sont
mal déployés pour résoudre de manière
réciproque les flux migratoirees qui
étouffe l'île de Mayotte dans son élan
économique par exemple la charte commune
état département qui pose les bases d'un
cadre stratégique de partenariat entre
la France et le Comor s'avère un
excellent outil de régularisation mais
qui n'apporte aucun résultat
probant sur ce point on sait les
difficultés liées aux
TF à mayott l'inté ation des étrangers à
Mayotte qui sont généralement des
ressortissants comoriens est un sérieux
problème que l'État se doit de résoudre
avec les élus maorés avant de les
intégrer il faudrait d'abord que les
autorités parviennent à mieux coordonner
leur politique pour bien maîtriser les
flux migratoire et cela relève d'abord
d'une mission
régalienne aujourd'hui je demande que le
Sénat apporte davantage son soutien à la
résolution de ce problème
épuneux c'est
pourquoi je
soutiendrai la question
préalable je vous remercie merci mon
cher
collègue la discussion générale est
clause nous passons maintenant à
l'examen de la motion tendante à opposer
la question préalable déposée par
Monsieur François Noël buffet au nom de
la commission des lois vous avez la
parole
ch
cèg je savais que c'était
périlleux madame le
ministre monsieur prés de la commission
des lois il vient de disparaître le
voilà mes chers collègues voilà je en
application des dispositions de
l'article 44 Alen 3 du règlement je
propose à cette tribune au Sénat de
décider qu'il n'y a pas lieu de
poursuivre la délibération sur le projet
de loi relatif au droits des
étrangers pour les raisons que j'ai déjà
longuement exposé tout à l'heure mais
permettez-moi de peut-être de les
reprendre
rapidement ce
texte dont le Sénat est saisi en
nouvelle lecture vise à revoir
l'architecture des titres de séjour en
créant
notamment un titre de séjour PL annuel
et améliorer les procédures
d'éloignement des étrangers en situation
irrégulière en première lecture notre
Sénat le Sénat avait adopté des
solutions différentes de Cell de
l'Assemblée nationale en maintenant
notamment les équilibres de la loi du 16
juin 2011 relative à l'immigration
l'intégration et à la
nationalité le Sénat avait aussi fait le
choix pour certaines dispositions de
s'inscrire dans la logique du texte en
poursuivant les efforts de clarification
et de simplification
entrepris et en proposant d'améliorer
les mécanismes votés ainsi sans remettre
en cause le principe d'une procédure
accélérée de contestation des
obligations de quitter le territoire
national prise dans certains motifs pour
certains motifs le Sénat avait
circonscrit cette procédure aux seuls
étrangers débouter du droit d'asile en
considérant que cette catégorie là
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière
pose des difficultés les plus grandes en
matière
d'éloignement s'appuyant également sur
les directives la directive retour le
Sénat avait par ailleurs étendu la durée
maximale des mesures d'interdiction de
retour à 5 ans au lieu des 3 ans
proposés par le texte sans durée
maximale en cas de menace grave à
l'ordre publ au regard du contexte de
menace actuelle cette dernière mesure
avait me semble-t-il toute sa
justification
enfin constatant la volonté du
gouvernement de promouvoir l'assignation
à résidence le Sénat avait créer deux
mécanismes permettant d'accroître les
exigences en matière de garantie de
représentation des recites la validation
par le maire de l'attestation
d'hébergement et la possibilité d'un
cautionnement par l'étranger en nouvelle
lecture le texte adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale ne prend en aucun compte
aucune des préoccupations majeures
qu'avait exprimé notre assemblée à
travers plusieurs amendements
d'importance adoptés en première lecture
ni même de manière plus surprenante des
disposition ayant pour objet le garantir
l'efficacité de mesures proposées par le
texte lui-même donc par le gouvernement
en outre des dispositions nouvelles
ayant notamment des effets importants
sur le droit d'asile mais aussi sur le
service civique sans relation directe
avec les dispositions restantes en
discussion ont été introduite par les
députés lors de cet examen en nouvelle
lecture je rappelle que les députés ont
adopté un amendement du Gouvernement
modifiant le Code du service national
afin d'élargir les possibilités pour les
étrangers accéder au Service CIVI
conduisant à une réforme d'ampleur de ce
dispositif ils ont également supprimé
l'assignation à résidence sous
surveillance électronique d'un étranger
parent d'un enfant mineur ne disposant
pas de garantie de représentation je
redis que cette dernière initiative
était contradictoire et est
contradictoire avec l'objectif du texte
visant à éviter le placement en
rétention tout particulièrement pour les
mineurs enfin l'assemblée nationale a
adopté à l'initiative du gouvernement
toujours une disposition nouvelle en
matière d'asile permettant à l'autorité
administrative d'opposer
l'irrecevabilité à une demande d'asile
formulée en rétention au-delà des 5
premiers jours de celle-ci cette
disposition crée une dérogation au
principe affirmé par la loi du 29
juillet 2015 qui a été votée et relative
au droit d'asile selon laquelle seul l'
pra peut opposer l'irrecevabilité à une
demande d'asile sur ces trois derniers
des points qui me semblent
particulièrement importants quant aux
principes et quant à leurs conséquences
la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel en application de
l'article 45 de la Constitution les
amendements adoptés après la commission
mix paritaire doivent être en relation
directe je le redis avec une disposition
du texte encore en discussion ou
justifié par la nécessité de coordonner
des dispositions avec d'autres textes en
discussion au Parlement de permettre le
respect de la constitution de corriger
une erreur matérielle sincèrement mes
chers collègues de ces trois DISP ces
trois dispositions ne remplissent pas
ces conditions fixées pour pouvoir être
valablement maintenu dans le texte voté
par l'Assemblée nationale il semble donc
qu'il y ait sur ce point-là un problème
d'inconstitutionnalité très sérieux
c'est au bénéfice de ces explications
mes chers collègues monsieur le
Président Madame le Ministre
pardon que je propose que le Sénat vote
cette question préalable et renvoie à
l'Assemblée
devant ses responsabilités merci merci
monsieur le rapporteur la parole est à
Monsieur philippetenb contre la motion
et vous avez 10 minutes mon cher
collègue
Maxim monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues nous
débattons d'une question préalable sur
le de loi relatif au droits des
étrangers axé sur l'accueil
l'attractivité et la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine ce projet de
loi droit étrangers était un texte
équilibré et pragmatique lorsquil est
arrivé ici au Cénat en première lecture
mais malheureusement notre Haute
Assemblée a choisi de le détricoter
complètement et même de le dénaturer et
je crois que c'était quelque chose qui a
été largement dénoncé ici
cette opposition stérile fondée sur des
raisonnements simplistes et caricaturaux
a d'ailleurs abouti mais qui s'en étonne
à une absence d'accord en commission
mixte paritaire et c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on charge la barque lorsqu'on
agite les chiffons rouges il est ensuite
difficile d'arriver à des Sit à des
solutions de
consensuelles alors le texte qui nous
est revenu de l'Assemblée heureusement
j'ai envie de dire a été corrigé et
retrouve à la la fois son humanisme et
sa fermeté qui sont les deux principes
conducteurs de l'action menée par le
gouvernement depuis le début de ce
quinquena en matière de droits des
étrangers à ce titre je crois qu'il faut
signaler je sais que Monsieur kucci en
est fort déçu que l'assemblée a dans sa
grande sagesse supprimé cette
proposition de débat annuel sur
l'immigration et sur l'établissement de
cota et je vous rappelle et je vous
rappelle et je vous rappelle que alors
que il y a quelques années monsieur
sorfeu était ministre de l'Intérieur il
avait eu aussi cette idée fulgurante
mais que après étude il l'avait enterré
car lui-même avait convenu que c'était
une disposition inutile et
contreproductive pourquoi pourquoi parce
que en France depuis 1974 il n'y a plus
d'immigration économique elle est
marginale pour donner un titre de
travail permettant le permettant à un
étranger de travailler il faut démontrer
il faut démontrer qu'aucun français ne
peut exercer cette fonction au
aujourd'hui l'immigration autorisée
c'est principalement le recroupement
familial des étrangers qui font venir
leur famille qui sont en règle ou des
Français qui épousent un étranger c'est
les étudiants et c'est l'asile c'est ça
les voies d'accès officielles en France
donc des débats sur des quotas c'est
pour des pays qui accueillent une
immigration économique en nombre parce
qu'elles ont des besoins importants
l'Australie le Canada donc ce n'est pas
du tout adapté à la France et
voilà c'était un des chiffrons rouges
inuties et qui n'avait qu'un objectif
d'affichage politique et je crois que il
fallait dépasser ces débats stérides les
députés ont également fait preuve de
fermeté comme on témoigne certains des
amendements adoptés je pense à la
possibilité même si elle peut être
débatue et je sais que sur tous les
bancs cette question n'est pas tranchée
puisqueelle a ouvert la possibilité pour
l'autorité administrative de déclarer
irrecevable une demande d'asile
présentée au-delà des 5 premiers jours
de rétention dans le seul but de faire
obstacle à l'exécution de mesure
d'éloogement et il y a aussi cette autre
mesure de fermeté prise par l'Assemblée
avec la procédure accéléré de
contestation des obligations de quitter
le territoire français pour tous les
étrangers et non plus seulement pour les
seuls déboutés alors voilà nous avions
eu des débats ici au Sénat des débats
qui c'est vrai ont été parfois un petit
peu un petit peu virulent mais je crois
que ces débats méritaent d'être
poursuivis et aujourd'hui nous avons
cette question préalable qui vise en
fait à stopper tout débat et à nous
empêcher de continuer à chercher à
améliorer le texte de chercher à
défendre nos convictions de chercher à
convaincre et le rôle d'un parlementaire
c'est bien
celui-là monsieur buffet a justifié
cette question préalable avec deux
raisons premièrement l'assemblée n'a
rien retenu du texte adopté par le Sénat
et deuxièmement l'assemblée a ajouté de
nouvelles dispos position en ce qui
concerne le premier point je l'ai
expliqué beaucoup des amendements qui
avaient été votés par la majorité
sénatoriale à quelques jours des
élections régionales étaient des
amendements d'affichage très politique
qui n'avaient rien de pragmatique et
rien
d'efficace
alors mais je le démontrer pour les
quotas même monsieur brissortefeu que
j'ai du mal à citer quand même mais sur
ce point-là avait après étude reconnu
que ces quotas n'avaient aucun sens et
c'était et c'était le principal chiffon
rouge
la majorité sénatoriale avait également
et ça a été rappelé par le
rapporteur supprimé un des éléments
essentiel de la réforme c'était le cœur
de la réforme que ce titre pluriannuel
qui a pour objectif d'en finir avec les
fils d'attente devant les préfecturesù
nous avons des étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui doivent venir plusieurs
fois dans l'année faire des queux
et engorger complètement nos préfectures
et donc vous proposiez là également de
supprimer ce tytre de séjour
plurriannuel d'en faire une exception
alors que c'est vraiment le cœur du
dispositif vous aviez également réduit
le nombre de personnes concernées par de
nouveaux droits et durcit certaines
mesures en matière d'interdiction de
séjour liant une nouvelle fois étranger
et ordre public et donc c'est vrai que
lorsquon est dans une démarche très
politicienne très d'affichage politique
la réaction de l'assemblée a été je le
regrette he de ne pas forcément rentrer
dans le débat au fond mais de dire nous
refusons de débattre de ces questions
fallait-il pour autant couper tout débat
nous nous croyons pas nous pensons qu'il
faut poursuivre le débat quoi qu'il
arrive vous savez nous sommes dans
l'opposition depuis quelques temps
maintenant ici au Sénat ça nous empêche
pas de déposer des amendements et de
chercher à convaincre même si c'est
rarement avec une suite favorable j'en
conviens voilà sinon je crois aussi
qu'il faut dire que les ajouts qui ont
été opérés par l'Assemblée relève du bon
sens pour répondre au second point moi
je ne vois pas pourquoi vous êtes vend
debout contre l'ouverture du service
civique aux étrangers qui peut être un
excellent facteur
d'intégration vous dites qu'il faut
intégrer les étrangers c'est en effet
une des priorités de l'action
gouvernementale mais est-ce que
justement ouvrir la possibilité du
service civique n'était pas un facteur
d'intégration je crois que ça méritait
au moins un débat et de ne pas être
balayé comme vous l'avez
fait sur tous ces points dans le cadre
du débat nous aurions pu enrichir le
texte en discuter éventuellement
l'amender peut-être même sur certains
points comme le droit d'asile de manière
très large mais avec cette question
préalable vous évitez tout débat et vous
stoppez net la discussion
c'est ce déniis en fait de débat que
nous contestons aujourd'hui et c'est
pourquoi le groupe socialiste votera
contre cette question préalable car
c'est un signe extrêmement négatif que
de voir une assemblée parlementaire
refuser tout débat nous avons été élus
pour débattre les Français attendent que
sur un sujet aussi important que
l'immigration et les droits des
étrangers cela a été dit nous allions au
fond des débats je crois que ce n'est
pas rendre service au Sénat que de
réduire le Sénat à un rôle d'opposant
systématique qui refuse la discussion
sur un texte aussi important d'autant
que et je le dis nos débats ici ne sont
jamais inutiles puisque certains des
amendements qu'avait déposé ici le
groupe socialiste qui n'ont pas été
repris par la Haute Assemblée on finit
par aboutir à l'Assemblée nationale ce
qui montre que lorsqu'on arrive à
discuter lorsqu'on arrive à échanger des
arguments on finit petit à petit par
obtenir quelques satisfaction et moi
j'ai été très heureux de constater que
quatre des amendements qui avaient été
refusés ici au Sénat on finit par
aboutir à l'Assemblée je pense notamment
à l'obstention de plein droit de la
carte de résident lors du second
renouvellement je pense à la possibilité
pour l'étranger qui sollicite un titre
plurannuel dans le cadre d'un changement
de statut de se voir délivrer le titre
sollicité sans délivr ance préalable une
carte de séjour temporaire je pense à
l'encadrement des cas de placement en
rétention d'un étranger accompagné d'un
mineur et je pense à l'accès des
association humanitaire de défense des
droits des étrangers aux zone d'attente
donc on le voit le travail d'amendement
finit par aboutir c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs le groupe socialiste
républicain avait déposé ici h nouveaux
amendements pour poursuivre le débat
essayer de convaincre ici au Sénat et
puis faire avancer aussi nos idées à
l'Assemblée il y avait des des sujets
importants comme garantir l'accès des
victim de traite ou du proxinétisme à la
carte de séjour plurannuel comme la
compétence de l'autorité administrative
qui doit être liée pour laavis médicale
en cas de demande de séjour pour soins
comme le délai de 2 jours ouvrés pour
permettre à la justice enfin à la
personne étrangère de faire appel à un
avocat tous ces aspects là nous
considérons que c'était des aspects qui
méritaent débat et qui méritaent
d'avancer voilà malheureusement je crois
que sans dévoiler le résultat du vote
nous nous acheminons vers un vote
positif pour cette question préalable
qui va couper cours à tout débat nous
retournons en fait à une opposition
frontale entre deux visions du droit des
étrangers je ne crois pas que ça soit
souhaitable il faut toujours essayer de
chercher des compromis et de trouver des
solutions consensuelles ça ne sera pas
le cas sur ce point alors malgré tout je
dois dire que à travers ce débat on voit
bien que vous continuez à chercher à
instrumentaliser les étrangers en France
à les présenter comme un danger comme un
danger qui malheureusement nourrit cette
thèse fallacieuse de l'envahissement du
pays thèse qui est largement reprise par
l'extrême droite et derrière laquelle
malheureusement vous courez pourtant et
ça sera ma conclusion je tiens ici à
dire que dans un monde globalisé il faut
tirer le meilleure partie d'une
immigration qui est incontourable lors
de l'explication de vote j'avais rappelé
les nombreux Français étrang qui avvré
pour le pays et qui éta des exemples je
voulais juste je concl en citant
l'exemple américain où le quart des prix
Nobel on été attribués à des personnes
iimmigration nous grandiss en
accétranger je crois que pour touteses
raisons le débat dotre poursuivi
merci est l'avis du Gouvernement madame
la
ministre
le président monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
souhaiteraient au nom du ministre de
l'Intérieur dire quelques mots dans ce à
ce moment du débat sur cette sur cette
motion de rejet préalable le Bernard
Caseneuve est retenu à l'Assemblée
nationale sur le sur le texte sur l'état
d'urgence et je je voulais dire
m'exprimer en en son nom à ce moment euh
vous avez vous avez dit Monsieur le
monsieur le rapporteur regretter que
l'Assemblée nationale est d'un revers de
main balayer le texte que vous aviez
adopté en première lecture je pense que
le gouvernement ne peut qu'être en
désaccord avec cette cette cette
affirmation on l'avait vu lors de lors
de vos débats le texte que nous avions
proposé tel qu'il a été amendé par les
députés celui que vous aviez adopté
présentait des divergences
importantes et les philosophies on peut
dire ou les points de vue étaient euh
d'une certaine façon difficilement
conciliaable sur certains points pour
autant vous aviez ici au Sénat apporté
des des améliorations significatives au
texte et ces améliorations ont été
conservées contrairement à ce que j'ai
cru entendre tout à l'heure de la même
façon elles ont permis d'améliorer
encore après vos modifications le texte
en nouvelle lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale s'agissant des désaccords des
désaccords de fond et que leés que la
commission mixte paritaire a mis en
évidence vous avez voulu me semble-t-il
nous
semble-t-il maintenir le statut quo et
le contenu de la loi du 16 juin de 2011
or précisément l'ambition qui était
celle du gouvernement était de
moderniser et d'améliorer le droit des
étrangers considérant que le statut quo
justement n'était pas satisfaisant vous
avez proposé de limiter à la portion
congrue le titre de séjour pluriannuel
et de maintenir pour les étrangers qui
résident dans notre pays les
tracasseries administratives dont chacun
connaît les conséquences dégradation des
conditions d'accueil précarisation des
droits au séjour limitation de
l'immigration euh du talent et de la
connaissance et il était important que
nous avancions sur ces questions ensuite
comme je l'ai dit vous avez revendiquer
le statut quo concernant le régime du
contentieux de la rétention issu de la
loi du 16 juin
2011 euh chacun sait pourtant que
celui-ci réussit l'exploit d'être
doublement insatisfaisant euh avec à la
fois sur le plan du respect du droit et
sur le plan de l'efficacité des
procédures de reconduite que le
gouvernement comme il a eu l'occasion de
le rappeler et le fera à chaque fois que
nécessaire les échecs de la politique
d'éloignement mené par la majorité
précédente et qui n'ont été dissimilés
que par les statistiques faut aussi à
certain moment et en ce moment dire les
dire les choses en première lecture vous
aviez aussi défendu ça a été redit dans
vos dans vos interventions défendu des
Côa annuel
d'immigration nous avions l'occasion de
dire que que c'était ni conforme à nos
valeurs républicaines ni à nos principes
constitutionnels ni à nos engagements
internationaux sur ces trois questions
les oppositions étaient profondes et
trop profondes sans doute pour que nous
puissions arriver à un accord mais cela
ne signifie pas encore monsieur le
rapporteur que le travail du Sénat a été
ignoré et qu'il n'en restera rien je
vais essayer de vous dire sur quel sur
quel point euh des améliorations ont été
apportter et ce ne sont pas des points
mineurs les propositions que vous avez
faites ont été ont été reprises et pour
cela je souhaiterais vous remercier
monsieur le rapporteur et remercier le
Sénat de sa contribution l'Assemblée
nationale a en effet maintenu l'article
8 B a que vous aviez introduit et par
lequel vous aviez précisé les
dispositions du Code de l'entrée du
séjour des étrangers et du droit d'asile
relative à la réserve d'ordre public en
matière de délivrance et de
renouvellement des titres de C sé jour
ces précisions étaient tout à fait
bienvenues et ne manqueront pas d'être
utiles dans l'application de la loi et
encore une fois je tiens à vous
remercier pour cela de la même façon les
députés ont maintenu la possibilité que
vous aviez introduite dans le texte en
première lecture à l'article 15 de
prolonger une interdiction de retour
au-delà de 5 ans dès lors qu'il existe
une menace pour l'ordre public
l'assemblée a également voté conforme
les modifications vous aviez apporté à
l'article 16 portant sur le contentieux
des obligations de quitter le territoire
français prise outreemère par ces
modifications vous avez pérénisé le
régime dérogatoire qui existe en
Guadeloupe à saint-martelémie tenant
compte d'une réalité locale bien
spécifique en outt le Sénat est à
l'origine de garanties nouvelles qui là
encore ont été maintenu par l'Assemblée
nationale et même précisé vous aviez
monsieur le rapporteur introduit un
article 22 B a qui reprend l'une des
préconisations du rapport que vous dont
vous êtes le co-auteur avec avec Madame
Iliane Assassi au terme de cet article
vous aviez rendu obligatoire la
délivrance aux étrangers qui font
l'objet d'une assignation à résidence
d'une information sur les modalités
d'exercice de leur droit et là aussi
c'est important enfin l'initiative de
Philippe caltenbach et du groupe
socialiste et des républicains du Sénat
dont je veux remercier de la grande
implication et de la qualité des travaux
vous aviez apporté un fondement
législatif à l'accès des associations de
défense des droits des étrangers aux
d'attente il s'agit de l'article 23 bis
qui est également un point important de
la même façon vous aviez adopté en
première lecture un autre amendement du
groupe socialiste visant à garantir que
la rétention des familles avec enfants
s'effectue toujours dans des locaux
adaptés à leur accueil et là aussi c'est
un point important à nos yeux vos
travaux enfin auront permis de proposer
des pistes d'amélioration approfondie en
nouvelle lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
vous avez sécurisé la procédure
d'escorte au consulat prévu par
l'article 18 du projet de loi en
introduisant la possibilité d'entré au
domicile de l'étranger assigné à
résidence en cas d'obstruction de sa
part et après autorisation du juge des
libertés et de la détention et cette
disposition a ensuite été généralisé par
l'Assemblée nationale à toutes les
assignations à résidence je veux enfin
dire un mot au sujet des nouveautés
introduites en nouvelle lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est dans un
esprit de rigueur et d'apaisement que
nous avons précisé certains question je
veux insister sur ce point nous l'avons
fait dans le respect absolu de la
procédure
parlementaire les si les conditions
d'accès des étrangers au services
civiques ont dû être précisées c'est
parce que la disposition de coordination
qui avait été introduite en première
lecture présentai des imperfections et
n'avaiit pas été à notre sens
suffisamment travaillé les dispositions
nouvelles apportées en première lecture
ont également rendu nécessaire
l'introduction de mesures d'articulation
avec la loi relative à la la réforme du
droit d'asile adoptée l'été dernier la
loi du du 29 juillet 2015 afin que nous
puissions en préserver les équilibres là
encore c'était important pour toutes les
raisons que je viens d'évoquer le
gouvernement ne peut monsieur le
rapporteur que déplorer le dépôt de
cette motion de rejet dont il est
souhaitable de de rejet préalable pardon
dont il est souhaitable et dont nous
souhaitons toutefois malgré tout pour
toutes les raisons que j'ai dites
qu'elle soit rejetée euh je laisse le
Sénat bien entendu son appréciation mais
je ne manque pas une dernière fois de
vous remercier pour la qualité de vos
débats et de vous remercier pour les
contributions que vous avez apporté à ce
texte et qui demeureront malgré votre
motion merci mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs merci madame la ministre je
vais maintenant donner la parole à
Monsieur Savin pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues lors de l'examen en
première lecture du projet de loi
relatif au droits des étrangers en
France le Sénat a beaucoup travaillé
afin de faire évoluer ce texte et
notamment le clarifier à travers les
travaux du rapporteur François Noël
buffet dont je salue le travail le
groupe des Républicains a largement
contribué à cette évolution du texte le
travail réalisé au sein de notre belle
institution na tout fois pas été prise
en compte par le gouvernement et sa
majorité parlementaire à l'Assemblée et
le test que nous étudions désormais ne
sans pas répondre aux attentes de nos
concitoyens concernant cette question
majeure qui est le droit des étrangers
en France nous sommes déçus par le que
le travail abouti sur ces travers et
trouvé si peu d'écho et que de nombreux
dispositifs voté dans cet hémicycle a
été détricoté avec l'assentiment du
gouvernement par l'Assemblée nationale
le Sénat avait pourtant fait le choix de
la simplification et du renforcement du
mécanisme centraux en CE qui concerne
les étrangers sur le territoire de la
République française je je souhaite
développer ici ici deux points que le
Sénat av est particulièrement remodelé
lors de l'examen du texte en première
lecture et qui me semble important ainsi
qu'un nombre de nos collègues tout
d'abord concernant l'architecture des
titres de séjour plurannuel proposé par
votre gouvernement il me semble
aujourd'hui nécessaire que les préfets
continue de disposer d'un pouvoir
d'appréciation dans le cadre de la
procédure administrative de plus c titre
plus pr annuel ne doivent pas se
généraliser mais consister en une
exception claire et définie par le
législateur notamment dans le cadre des
contrats d'intégration républicaine et
d'une pratique d'un niveau de langue
française suffisant afin de pouvoir
bénéficier d'un tel dispositif ces
premiers éléments que notre assemblée
avait validé ont toutefois été supprimés
par votre majorité gouvernementale la
seconde disposition que je souhaite ici
développer le rôle du Parlement
concernant la politique d'immigra
nationale l'immigration et d'intégration
que le Sénat avait apporté il semble en
effet important qu'au 21e siècle les
représentants de la notion puissent
conduire un débat approfondi sur ces
dimensions et notamment sur la
possibilité que le Sénat avait offert au
Parlement de définir le nombre
d'étrangers accueillis en France en
fonction des activités des capacités
d'accueil et des moyens d'intégration
comme l'a parfaitement développé notre
collègue Ros carucci enfin je souhaite
profiter de mon intervention pour vous
interpeller madame la secrétaire d'État
chargée de la formation professionnelle
l'apprentissage sur la question du droit
des jeunes sportifs mineurs étrangers en
France je regrette en effet qu'aucun
aspect du sujet n'a été abordé dans ce
projet de loi nulle part n'a été évoquée
la situation de ce jeune sportif sou de
moin 16 ans de grande majorité d'origine
africaine qui sont par miné abandonné au
sein des clubs professionnels de foot
merci mon cher collègue c'est pour
toutes ces raisons que je soutiendrai
donc la proposition de notre rapporteur
merci je vais consulter le Sénat sur la
question préalable et j'ai été saisi d'e
demande de scrutin public par la
commission des lois sur la motion de
questions préalable déposé par la même
commission des lois je vous rappelle que
l'avis du Gouvernement est défavorable
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du
règlement
voici voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 156 sur la motion numéro 1
tendante à opposer la question au
préalable nombre de votants 342 nombre
de suffrages exprimés
325 pour l'adoption 187 contre
138 le Sénat a adopté la question
préalable en conséquence il n'a pas
adopté le projet de loi en nouvelle
lecture voilà pour le rejet hier en 2e
lecture du projet de loi relatif au
droits des étrangers un texte qui
cristallise de grandes crispation entre
le Sénat majoritairement à droite et
l'Assemblée nationale majoritairement à
gauche alors s'il est vrai qu'il est
habituel que l'immigration voit des
clivage partisan au Parlement c'est
d'autant plus paradoxal que les
parlements nationaux ont très peu de
marge de manœuvre sur ce sujet en effet
le droit des étrangers est très encadré
par les directives européennes vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site sur
publsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 16h30 avec Sénat 360 présenté par
Delphine girérard très bonne journée sur
les chaînes
parlementaires